my frame for optionality is well you can
make your own luck
so look for those asymmetric
opportunities
and just snap them up just build a
portfolio
over years and um you don't
know you can never be sure if
they will pay off if you take one of
these speculative plays
and probably they won't uh you know the
the chances are against you in any given
one of them but the idea is you're
building a portfolio
one of them is going to pay off at some
point in time
at which point you're going to be okay
so
you just keep stacking up opportunities
wherever you see them
and maximizing your chances of getting
lucky
richard meadows welcome to the show
thank you for having me
pleasure to have you on man so
optionality what is
optionality uh the simplest definition
of optionality is the right but not the
obligation to take action
so you can do something if you want but
you don't have to
and my argument is that optionality is a
pretty good proxy for human flourishing
in general
and just being able to maximize your
capabilities as a human being
and have the maximum range of
possibilities open to you so would that
suggest that naturally as humans
our level of well-being and flourishing
is directly proportional to how many
different options we can take in life
uh i think it's it's less it's less of a
quantitative thing and more qualitative
so it's about
uh the caliber of the options that are
available to you
so i draw a distinction between having a
lot of choices
in the consumer capitalism uh frame
where you can go to the supermarket and
choose between emptying different
varieties of pasta sauce or
laundry detergent but like having high
quality options
is more important so being able to
you know work in a career that you that
you find meaningful or satisfying or
being able to have good relationships
with the people around you
um that's that's really the key and it's
not so much
about being sort of floating on cloud
nine and being euphoric
all the time but also having the right
to
choose to do things that are really hard
or that involves some degree of
not necessarily suffering but perhaps
some degree of hardship or sacrifice
because it's sort of a broader
definition of human flourishing that
goes beyond the
simple hedonistic pleasures how do you
see
optionality manifesting in the real
world then that's a nice concept but
what does it actually look like when it
enters our lives
yeah so i've got a framework for
cultivating optionality that basically
looks like
taking this lens and applying it to all
the
little decisions of daily life so i'll
give you a couple of concrete examples
um so what we're really looking for
uh overall is any sort of decision
or action you can take that has a a
small
cost or a small downside it doesn't
require a lot of money or effort to take
out the option
but it leads to an open-ended upside so
it could
it could have basically unlimited
possibility and it could be
really transformative for your life
so one simple example of that would be
uh
you know like uh emailing someone you
admire that takes you
two minutes or uh or whatever it might
be to pen an email to someone
and amazingly with the you know with the
power of the internet you can get in
touch with just about anyone
that you can imagine and then they might
even write you back and it could be the
beginning of a
mentorship or you could have some kind
of relationship or just uh
find it to be a meaningful interaction
so
the pos uh the the downside cost there
is um
you know very small it's not that hard
to do and
the possible the possible uh positive
outcome is very large or
open-ended so in most cases nothing will
happen maybe they don't email you back
and that's fine because
you've lost essentially not and nothing
um but in the
event that they do there's a sort of the
potential for transformative upside so
my idea is to take this framework of
optionality which is a concept from
the world of finance and and
just look at the decision look at a lot
of decisions through this framework and
look for those asymmetries so
what's the downside what's the upside
and what can i do that has a pretty
small effort
and might lead to a large payoff and
then just systematically
collect as many of those options as you
can and build a sort of portfolio so
even if most of them don't work out
you're sort of
constantly attuning yourself to
serendipity and
luck you know it's a system for making
your own luck
um so yeah i could give more examples of
those sort of asymmetries if you like
and there's also
the negative optionality which is
something like being in debt
so if you take on a consumer debt you
have the obligation to do something but
not the right so it's an
inversion of the original formula um and
again one of the most powerful things i
would argue that anyone can do
is to remove those sources of negative
optionality in your life so
be extremely cautious on situations
where
the upside the possible return the
reward the bounty
is limited so it's fixed it's capped but
the potential
downside is is bottomless or infinite
so that this is the sort of the russian
roulette archetype where
you spin the barrel maybe you win 100
bucks or sort of impress your mates at
bar
but in the event that you lose you lose
everything
lights out so that's the framework um
hunt for the asymmetric opportunities
which are loaded in your favor
and steer well clear of the
the options and decisions which have a
negative asymmetry
where there's a possibility that will
lead to some kind of total ruin
what are some of the other common
situations that you see people getting
negative optionality wrong or that
negative asymmetry
yeah so in the financial realm which is
my sort of main area of expertise
um one of them would be something quite
boring like
let's say you've got a car and uh
laura's in the uk but you drive around
without insurance um
now your potential upside from not
bothering to take out insurance i mean
like indemnity or
liability insurance is you're saving x
hundred dollars or pounds on the
insurance premium right
now the potential downside is that you
t-bone someone's jaguar in section
and you're on the hook for whatever it
might be several hundred thousand pounds
or
you're you're sort of out of commission
altogether um
so i think insurance is like almost an
inversion of
the concept of optionality because it
protects you against those large
downside risks another good example
might be
during the you know the covert uh
19 situation or disaster preparedness
more generally whereby
it's helpful to have
a bunch of medicines that you need
stockpiled and some basic food and water
and supplies in the event that something
unexpected happens um
it costs you very little to take those
precautions i mean you're gonna
you're gonna eat the food either way
it's sort of bugger all in the scheme of
things
uh and in the event that you need it
you're really really really gonna need
it so
failing to take simple protective
measures like that
i would also argue as sort of a failure
of imagination and uh
and a kind of a common uh risk
management mistake where people are just
like
not necessarily thinking about it
through this lens of like
there are these big risks out here do i
have an opportunity to
mitigate them by taking some relatively
cheap
straightforward actions the number one
rule of the game is to never be out of
being able to play
exactly right yep yep you can take risks
you can lose
it's fine it's it's necessary to lose
but you can never lose so bad that you
can't come back
did you see bill ackman's trade at the
start of this year
i don't think so tell me about it so
it's being dubbed the new big
short so obviously the big short was
that famous film uh made about
the fellow christian bale played that
shorted the housing market
and bill ackman who i'm sure that you
know very famous short seller on wall
street he was the guy that was
adamant that herbalife was a scam and i
think he's still short on herbalife even
though he hasn't taken them down yet
the beginning of this year he's he
foresaw
that kovid was going to have a
significantly bigger impact on
the entire world financial market than
anybody had priced in
so he took out a very special type of
insurance
um which is kind of like put options
it's it's a bit
sort of complex to explain and i
definitely can't do it but there's also
some youtube videos out there if anyone
wants to dig into it
further but the the long and short of it
is he made more money
than the man from the big short and the
difference is it didn't take him three
and a half years
it took him about four weeks billions
billions and billions of dollars in the
space of about four weeks because this
man first saw that
and that's kind of the same right like
the potential risk that he had
was to just continue taking over with
this particular type of insurance
but the upside was so asymmetric in his
favor
that it made total sense yeah yeah
yeah no that's interesting so um the guy
who uh who i've learned the most about
optionality from
is called nasim talib and he's an
options trader
and he did something very similar during
the
2008-2009 global financial crisis
whereby
i think he was buying put options and i
think he was buying out of money puts
and he was sort of
every day loading up and and taking
these small
manageable losses and he could see
something bad was going to happen with
the build-up of
accumulation of risk within the
financial system and so when it all went
to pieces
you know everyone lost their shirt
except for him because he'd been waiting
for just such an opportunity
with these small steady predictable kind
of
losses and then the upside when it came
yeah is the same kind of scenario where
it's essentially
it could it could run on forever and so
my understanding is that he made his
fortune um
by being a bit of a contrarian and
positioning himself to to profit from
misfortune and disaster
um so yeah kudos to uh kudos to bill
eckman too i have to have a look at that
yeah he crushed it man you're to love
that story another good example
of negative asymmetry would be
having unprotected sex or texting whilst
driving
are you talking about a marginal
increase
in pleasure for a potential 18-year
commitment or a health a health risk
um and then the equivalent for texting
whilst driving
like you know you're looking at
potentially
time in jail a fine at the bottom end or
ending some poor person's life because
you're not properly looking
or for what for replying to a meme a
little bit quicker in a group chat that
everyone's going to forget about within
the next five seconds
yeah that's quite i love that i wish i'd
included the um
unprotected sex one in the book that's
fantastic yeah
it's a yeah it's a conversation that
we've had a number of times looking for
these sort of asymmetric
opportunities and avoiding these
asymmetric risks do you see
um any asymmetries manifesting more in
the sort of social realm
rather than just in the financial realm
did you come across any of those
yeah i have um i think most of them are
positive
asymmetries that you can exploit but i'd
rather uh sorry i'll
touch on the on the negative ones to
begin with so
i think um the main negative one would
be
just this the social contagion effect
whereby the people you surround yourself
by
uh are responsible they kind of shape
you and mold you
and they shape they shape your outcomes
in a really surprising way just because
humans are so
malleable and so um we're so good at
kind of
unconsciously imitating one another so
something that i say which might come
across as quite mercenary and cruel in
the book but i think is a
actually a necessary thing to do is to
excise the the really toxic people from
your life if you're unlucky enough to
have them in your life and perhaps
having taken steps to try and
actually help them and do something
about it but um
yeah there's this phenomenon whereby
things don't get
worse in a linear fashion they tend to
uh spiral downwards faster and faster so
if you have
if you're a social group if your friends
or your family or whoever it might be
constantly exerting a negative influence
over you
the hard and possibly probably correct
thing to do
is to get some distance from them and
possibly you know
you may or may not cut them out of your
life altogether but definitely sort of
acknowledge this idea that uh you know
you can
uh you don't you don't have to you don't
have to feel obligated to
to be tethered to someone just because
you have a shared history indefinitely
and i certainly found that quite
powerful idea
myself having been brought up with the
notion that uh
you know it's like it's very
you have to love unconditionally from
now until the end of time for your
friends or family
and there's no there's no way to get any
distance from that
um yeah and then the even more positive
happy side of the equation is just
uh it's a big old world
and it's never been easier to connect
with people
and incredible and it's incredibly easy
to get in touch with people i mean i
kind of
i know this i'm so i'm a journalist by
trade and
it's surprisingly easy to find people's
contact details online
so it's mostly a question of uh i don't
know what you'd call it motivation
or confidence or something like that
where you can
put yourself out there and
and sort of find your tribe of people
more easily than at any other point in
history
and the manner in which you do so uh
usually involve
something like being good at email or
having a presence on twitter or on
uh you know contributing to open source
libraries if you're a programmer or
inhabiting certain forums
or putting yourself the the next level
version of that would be
changing your geographic proximity so
actually upping and moving to
san francisco if you're big into tech or
new york if you begin to
finance or whatever it might be and
putting yourself in the proximity of the
kind of people who you are
likely to get along with so that's like
not as an attractive
option in so far as it requires you to
live in san francisco but
um uh yeah there's there's lots of
things that you can do to sort of build
social capital
uh that don't require a lot of effort
and that could potentially change your
life and i'm sort of speaking from
experience here
having having done that almost by
accident and i think that people have
this idea that you
can't really be strategic about things
like relationships like it's somehow
it's a it's gauche or it's not it's not
the done
thing um so i think if you apply this
framework where you actually say hey
this is important to me
i'm i'm going to put an effort in a
strategic
cultivated deliberate way that's really
powerful just having that real
having that realization and thinking
more carefully about where you're
devoting your your time and your energy
do you have any triggers
that help you to continue doing that in
life
one of the things that i often find is
i'll come across a concept
like this that we're discussing here
pretty much anything else to do with
personal growth
and the issue for the most part isn't my
buy-in i
fully believe that this could have a
really positive impact in my life
but i need to instantiate it somehow i
need to have a trigger
or some sort of little mantra or a
reminder of some kind
that allows me to actually enforce it
into reality
yeah i mean i like the idea of
chunking down difficult concepts into
little
mantras that you can remind yourself of
i definitely have a few of those myself
um actually i have like a almost like a
catcher
all mantra i'm not sure if i should even
say it out loud i will
um uh there's a line
i hope it doesn't lose its magic juju um
so
there's a line that goes at first say to
yourself what you would be and then do
what you have to do
uh which is from epic terrorists i think
you're you're sort of big into the the
stoics aren't you
um so you'd probably be familiar with
him but yeah it's just this idea of um
there ain't nothing to it but to do it
so um i have little tricks like that but
my
my main uh my main weapon for
making all these trade-offs in a
smoother fashion
you know making these short-term pain
long-term gain type
trade-offs is basically to
systematize everything and what i mean
by that
is put in place certain practices
and habits and constraints that
just make the process of getting to
where i want to be
smooth so it doesn't require willpower
on a
daily basis and in the realm of finance
an example of that would be
instead of sort of saying to myself i'd
like to
save x amount of money and i'll and i'll
try really hard not to
not to blow my pay packet just to
set up an automatic transfer after
payday that goes straight out of the
bank account
straight into your investment account
and then you have to
live on whatever's left over and at no
point in the process do you feel
friction or pain it's perfectly
automated
and you just you just get by and you
sort of adapt to the
to the new normal um of however much
you've you've left yourself for spending
money
uh and there's a there's a bunch of
tricks like that um
which i find really useful um for
both and both practically in terms of
actually implementing these
these what i think of as trades um and
psychologically in terms of knowing that
uh no matter what your outcome is
you're putting in the work so
you're following your system day after
day and you're doing the right things
and
maybe it will maybe it won't pay off um
immediately you don't know exactly when
it will pay off
and you don't know uh what form what
will the payoff look like
but you can feel good about the fact
that you're following your
your system and you're and you're
stacking up uh what what i think of as
these juicy asymmetric options
so um i should probably give a concrete
example of that as well which would be
something like
reading books i think has just like
changed my life probably
like no other practice has and the
reason that i
like to read books i mean quite apart
from the enjoyment factor is that
they're cheap you can buy them cheap or
you can get them from the library for
free
and then you don't know what's in there
you don't know what idea you're going to
encounter
what you practice you're going to pick
up when you sort of get to
gaze out upon the world through someone
else's eyes
so that's the small cost and the and the
very large potential upside
and then if you have this practice just
read just read a read a [ __ ] book
like read a book
um rather than watch tv or something
like that just
just read the [ __ ] book and then it
will pay off
at some point you don't you don't know
how you don't know
you don't know what it's going to be
until you
until you get there and it will it'll
surprise you every time
so the practice is is really what
matters you don't you it's not sort of
like
you have to see the future and predict
it's going to be exactly this and this
is going to lead me on to par this is
going to lead me to this path and that's
going to result in this opportunity
if you become the kind of person who
does such and such activity and i would
include
sort of reading in that bracket um it's
going to pay off
it's it's just gonna pay off and you can
feel good about that
so much to go through there man it
sounds like i'm uh talking to a kindred
spirit here
certainly one of the things that i've
done this year which has made a big
difference a little mantra i've had in
my head has been
this is why you're here so when things
get
hard or you feel discomfort the reminder
is that that's what you're here for
you're here for the slightly
uncomfortable learning experience
it's because you're learning something
difficult and worthwhile you're
there for the burn in the gym you're
there for the slight level of
hunger or tiredness or whatever it is at
the end of the day because you are on a
calorie restricted diet or because you
trained hard that day or whatever it
might be
this is why you're here lean into your
discomfort as if you invited it through
the door
and then talking about systematizing
some things that you want to do
um a good hack for that sleep with your
phone outside of your bedroom
and don't watch netflix after a
particular time at night the only choice
that you have to do
is to read a book or go to bed early
either way you win
so those are two ways that i've
instantiated uh
things that i want as long-term
lifestyle changes into a daily practice
one thing that i can see as a potential
problem here is
optionality being polarized with
optimizing like if you're always
exploring new options you can't exploit
and double down into certain things
how do you deal with that
right yeah i'm glad you brought that up
yeah so that's the that's the
fundamental trade-off
it's exploring and exploiting so um
well to begin with i think it's it's
never a bad idea
to maintain some level of uh optionality
so
in other words to devote some small
portion of your time to
be constantly exploring um and
opening up possibility right until
you're on desktop kind of thing
but then yeah after a certain point you
do have to switch
from uh from trying to open up new
possibilities to just actually execute
on something and sort of grab onto it
with both hands
so my model for that is
the optimal strategy for switching from
exploratory map mode to exploit mode
is a function of uh the volatility
of the domain in question and of your
time frame in that domain so it actually
varies depending on what it is that we
are talking about so um let's say that
you kind of you're in your teens or
early 20s and you're in you're trying to
get a handle on fitness and
nutrition and workouts and stuff it's a
good idea to
try a bunch of things and see what
sticks and see what you like and dislike
just again from the point of view of
not trying to do battle with yourself
and just make life
easy on yourself um so
that that would be a point where you
want to do a lot of exploration but
obviously you don't want to be that guy
who's constantly
doing the hot new thing and never
actually makes progress with anything
um it's the disease of the [ __ ] around
artists so you have to commit to
something
um yeah and then in that particular
domain
uh the volatility is not increasing
so that implies that as soon as you've
found something that you
are into and that you've that that you
feel good about
you actually sh basically lock them then
and just uh
get after it but indefinitely and you
can keep trying little things here and
there but you should
you should do just enough exploration to
find out about your own personal
preferences
and what works for you and then just get
after it so
the reason that that is that that you
should uh approach it that way is
because
the human body and the sort of um what
would you call it like
the the interventions for physical
fitness are not changing
like the barbell oh well calisthenics is
thousands of years old
and then the barbell i think is at least
a couple hundred years old and dumbbells
are dumbbells go right back to ancient
greeks so
um the body itself like it changes in on
an
on an evolutionary time scale but it
doesn't change over the course of
uh your own life except in in the sense
of aging
so uh because the domain is relatively
stable
you don't benefit from constantly
exploring and seeing if new
opportunities are cropping up like
it's not like the laws of physics will
change one day and suddenly um
you know crossfit will be out and um you
know
horseback people chase will be in or
something like it's there's there's no
point
in um positioning yourself for
uncertainty because there is no
real source of uncertainty there um and
then
to give a counterpoint of an opposite
sort of scenario
if we talk about career planning um
the argument that i make is that you
have to be open to exploration
much more so than in a domain like
physical physical health
because the world is changing there is a
lot of volatility
and you can't necessarily lock yourself
into something and then put your feet up
and just exploit
because um uh you know let's say
you have this model where you're a
specialist you're very good at one thing
and you have this is the old model of
the job for life 40 years with a golden
handshake
um you lock yourself into that you don't
broaden your skills
and then the you know the robot
apocalypse comes along and takes your
job
or yeah you know one of these sort of
uh i mean it doesn't even have to be one
of these outlandish ai scenarios just
the more mundane reality of industries
uh collapsing um so you've you've sort
of concentrated all of your career
capital in this one domain and it serves
you very well over the short term
and what you can't see in the background
is this there's this large accumulation
of sort of silent risk
so you might be all right you might make
it to retirement and
nothing bad happens but if your job
suddenly gets outsourced to
um you know to bangladesh or or
india or whatever it might be you're
screwed right you haven't you haven't
sort of
diversified yourself um you don't have
options so
um that's the downside resilience case
for
um always being exploratory and
in a domain which is changing quickly
but the more attractive side of that is
the
uh is looking at the upside um
you know like thinking about emerging
technologies and emerging fields things
are changing
things change now within the course of
our lifetime
times i mean within the course of like a
single year or a single
certainly a single decade and if you
have broad set of skills and you are
interested
you take an active interest in the world
you're sort of a curious person
you can position yourself to benefit
from these things i mean
like i think we're talking about bitcoin
just before we hit record
like imagine being one of those guys who
was
uh buying bitcoin for 30 cents each or
whatever because you're a geek and you
are interested in this new weird money
thing that no one else has ever heard of
um just because you you sort of um
taking a broad interest in life and not
just being like oh i'm the
you know i'm the i'm the chief widget
maker at the widget factory
and i'm good at what i do and i'll never
broaden my horizons any further than
that
yeah does that make sense absolutely man
yeah totally totally does
the um that insight
of optionality being inverse to the
level
of volatility within the system
makes a whole ton of sense
and i guess this year covered up raw
upheaval it's just the year of
optionality but if the future is
uncertain
how do we become more confident about
our decisions
shouldn't we just constantly be worried
about the future especially given
that technological change and society is
moving so fast now
yeah i mean this goes back to what i've
what i find to be psychologically
comforting about optionality so
at this point it might help to um sort
of mention my model for what is
what are the raw ingredients of
optionality so i break it down to
financial capital ie how much savings
you have um
and how little debt you have uh health
capital how fit and healthy and
energetic you are
social capital the strength and quantity
of your relationships and
and knowledge capital which is the depth
and breadth of your
skills and experiences and
um if you have if you focus
on all four of those buckets and you and
you're sure not to neglect any of them
i think you can kind of feel confident
about the future
even though you don't know what's coming
because let's say
uh 20 years from now i wouldn't have a
clue what i'm going to be doing
in a grain like in a fine-grained kind
of a sense
i don't know i don't know what sport
i'll be playing i don't know
exactly who my friends will be um and i
don't know what i'll be doing for work
but it will in any possible conceivable
scenario it will be extremely useful for
me to have
all four of those buckets full so that
i'm in a good position to
execute on whatever makes sense at that
point in time in my life and my career
and that future version of me
so i find it extremely comforting i mean
the probably the simplest and most
obvious version of this
is that anyone who's ever been in debt
or who's just had a shitty job and sort
of struggling to
make rent it's just a h
horrible position of being like you feel
powerless and
um you can't relax and it sort of bleeds
over into every other area of your life
and getting yourself in a position where
you've cleared your consumer debt for
example
and you've got like a bit of an
emergency fund in case um
the [ __ ] hits the fan it's just such a
it's such a powerful thing to do
and um it doesn't actually it's
you know like it's not changing anything
in the sense that
uh maybe you still work the same job and
your life looks more or less the same
but just
cycle even psychologically it's a
powerful position to be in
so yeah my argument is that
if you build up these sort of central
assets
these real real core valuable sources of
optionality
that alone is extremely comforting
it's never not going to be useful to
have a big chunk of change sitting in
the back so you're well positioned
maybe an investment opportunity comes
along maybe you're the guy
who finds out about the 30 cent bitcoins
right like
maybe uh you have an idea to start a
small business or you want to quit your
job and
take a sabbatical and launch a podcast
or whatever it might be
right like it's always going to be
useful
and you're like uh i don't know you
you just feel a certain sense of
security and possibility when you have
all of these things
topped up so i think that yeah the
future is kind of scary
but you can you can take some of the
sting out of it
and maybe even make it into an exciting
thing that would be the ideal well
you're kind of intrigued about what will
happen
i mean just from like yeah it is i mean
the world
is a fairly wild place right now and if
you can
if you can be the perfect stoic and sort
of remove yourself from it a little bit
it is almost
entertaining isn't that like it's just
so bizarre
yeah it is i got asked on a podcast i
was guesting on someone's show this week
and um they asked me like
what do you want to do in 50 years or
what what do you want written on your
tombstone
and i've never really been that good at
long-term planning
i think it's a function of being curious
if anyone is super super curious
you're always aware of just how many
things you're not doing
rather than the things that you are and
that to me is just like man i i don't
know
i get the sensation
i get the impression that when i start a
family i'm currently single and don't
have kids
but i get the impression that when i
start a family that's probably going to
be a sledgehammer of emotions that i'm
not ready for
um that's probably going to whitewash
most of the other stuff that i do in my
life
um but i might be wrong and given the
fact that i don't have that input and i
do tons of different things i was like i
don't know man
but that that you're you've given me a
comfort blanket though man like
i've just got options i've got
optionality um
yeah talking about the absolute
fundamentals what is the fundamental
best way
for someone to start opening up the
optionality they have in their life
um i think the single most important
thing that
anyone could do is probably uh
to attack the financial side of things
only because um well i'll actually i'll
tell you a little story so
uh i yeah i used to be a business
reporter
um had a good job enjoyed it very much
but i was starting to get a bit bored
and sort of getting that three-year edge
kind of thing
um and i i came across a subculture
called
financial independence retire early of
the fire movement
and i started getting into their stuff
and um
their main thing is like you you go into
kind of hardcore frugality mode and you
think really carefully about what's
important to you and
cut out any extraneous spending repay
debt aggressively
so i did that and i
i saved like enough a big enough chunk
of change to
um eventually sort of quit my job not in
a permanent retirement sense but in a
sort of
go take a sabbatical and work on other
projects since
um and that was like that was the the
lifestyle experiment that launched a
thousand ships kind of thing like that
was the most powerful
move that i've ever made i think um
and that is very accessible to most
people
so um what was the figure what was the
figure that you hit
i i hit a hundred thousand uh new
zealand dollars i think i
had it in the in the greenback about a
year later so
um yeah enough money for me to
go and travel and um do my thing and
have some space to breathe and think
about other projects
but not enough to retire on permanently
but just the principles of doing that
um are so powerful and like money
is not quite the same thing as
optionality but it's a it's a
it's a one of the most powerful
ingredients because
if you have money again you have the
right obligation to
spend it however you see fit so you
can't buy everything with money but you
can make a pretty good
uh you can make pretty good attempt at
it so
one underrated way of or maybe it's not
underrated but one powerful way of
of having more optionality is to take
that
use something like that frugal approach
i think especially when you're a young
man
or young woman and you can
you don't necessarily have to have an
extravagant lifestyle and try to keep up
with your peers
uh you can just sort of again it's a
short-term pain long-term gain thing you
can just uh
um sort of set yourself up to be in a
stronger position a little bit later
down the track
so i would highly encourage anyone who's
listening to this who is thinking about
like
they you don't feel if you don't feel
powerful if you don't feel like you're
in a position where you could
um where you could take a punt where you
could take a risk and
start your own project or where you
could walk away from your job because
you don't like your
boss you don't like your co-workers or
something um
yeah i think if you want to give
yourself some power what you want to do
is start being more intentional about
your spending i've got a lot of
tips in the book and um start trying to
build up the net worth start trying to
get rid of debt
and then that puts you in a really
strong position you can you can walk
away from a shitty situation
uh you can you can retrain or upskill
you can take a sabbatical to launch your
passion project you can cut back to
part-time hours
you know maybe to spend more time with
your family or or put more effort into
your health or whatever it might be
and i feel like that's an unusually
accessible
intervention that a lot of people could
use
and with the exception of people who are
really doing it tough and they're
already
sort of living on uh living on the smell
of an oily rag
um the great majority of young
you know trades people and professionals
could
use those strategies to get themselves
in a good position
um so yeah i think that's probably the
simplest step to get started
i remember i had a conversation while i
was on a photo shoot
maybe about six or seven years ago with
this older lady she's probably
about the age that i am now so i'm 32
she may be like 32 something like that
she's telling me about her and her
husband and i just bought my second
house
my first rental so i had my own and then
i bought a second one for
buy to let and she's telling me oh we've
just got our eighth house and i'm
talking about all the different things i
was like okay so what's the plan
and says well me and my husband have
done all of this we started a business
together we got married early it's
we started a business together and been
working on this business and building up
this property portfolio along
alongside it now we've got the manager
that's been with us for ages she's going
to run the business
and we front loaded our wealth and it
was that term that stuck with me so
we've
front loaded our wealth acquisition to
the point now
where we're gonna go travel the world
for the next four years
and then we're gonna settle down we're
gonna start a family and i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's it if
compounding
is the eighth wonder of the world which
i think we all agree it is
then front loading that wealth
as quickly as possible and it's
something that i i ended up doing
purely by fortune rather than by design
but it certainly put me in a strong
position now i have
my house plus three other rentals and i
have a a nice sort of steady pot of cash
and it also means that even my own home
because i let two rooms out to my
buddies even that's paid for
you know the whole world could go to
hell in a hand basket and i'd still like
how
it has done this year and financially i
know that i'm still sorted
and the converse of that is kind of the
live young wild and free advice that's
often given to people
and i get that like don't get me wrong
being young
is a time for you to adventure and to do
new things and to be a little bit
reckless as well
but at the top of this episode we talked
about the number one rule of the game is
to never be out of playing
and locking yourself in get going
bankrupt
getting into a business at 23 years old
with zero business experience and some
shady business partner and having a
bankruptcy
on your record or having a terrible
credit rating because you've run up a
ton of different cars on
repayment finance or a bunch of credit
cards because you wanted a new 50
inch tv or whatever you know upside 50
inch tv
downside [ __ ] credit rating for the next
decade
that's a pretty big asymmetric risk that
you've got going on there
so yeah yeah certainly and and that
the beautiful thing about front loading
wealth is that you front load if you
haven't done it up until now now is the
time to start
you can be 75 listening to this and
you're better off front loading wealth
than you are backloading it now
i had a morgan houselong guy that wrote
the psychology of money
and he said that 90
of warren buffett's net worth was
generated
after his 65th birthday
is that right holy [ __ ] that's how
powerful compounding is
yeah so yeah i'm i'm i'm all i'm all
about that front
front load that wealth why didn't you
decide
right i've got my hundred thousand here
uh i'm now going to
continue to work and just build up like
some
insane amount of cash and then go for
not
not whatever is the f i can't remember
what the first two letters are retire
early
financial independence retire early uh
why not like financial independence
retire
and all right age but wealthy as [ __ ]
yeah well um so
i could have done that that was my
initial plan but
the problem was that hey i'm as a
journalist and journalists are not
really making banks so it would have
been
a bit of a slog and i wouldn't have
retired super wealthy
i would have been um you know i would
have had a pretty
spartan existence if i wanted to do the
early retirement thing
which is fine you know i'm actually okay
with that
um but what i wasn't okay with was sort
of having this super
distant future focused um idea of
distant happiness so it took me right
out of the moment
because this idea of retired financial
independence retire early is like
the whole point of the game is to check
out the earliest opportunity so it's
very
it's a very kind of negative framing um
work is bad
and you must escape right so um
i wasn't prepared to keep doing my job
which i was no longer wildly
interested in or 10 or 15 more years
um to get to the point where i could
retire properly because i had all these
other
things that i wanted to experiment with
and also i was in
i'd hadn't done my overseas experience
which is a
grand tradition in new zealand you have
to go out and have your gap year or
or whatever and do the banana pancake
trail and that sort of thing
um so i didn't want to squander my youth
and my mobility and
um and sort of lock myself into this
future thing so i just decided
like i'm gonna i'm gonna pull the plug
right now um this is enough
to make some big changes to my life and
you know maybe look for some higher
leverage
opportunities so um uh you know like
being a salary owner is fine it's great
in some way in many ways it's sort of
comfortable and you have that stability
um but i think i like that naval line
that
you know the way to get wealthy is to
own something
is to own a piece of something like you
with your houses or you know you with
your podcast or
um you know you own a stake in a
business you start your own business
you the and the fundamental difference
here is you capture the upside
right not your boss not the shareholders
of the
the conglomerate that you work for um
possibly there's
there's a there's a stronger element of
downside risk and it's a bit more of a
speculative play but you get to capture
all the gravy
so that's that's like i mean thank god
that
i did quit my job and go off and wander
and sort of um try some of these
higher leverage uh more speculative
place because that's actually how
um you know the other path would have
been okay i could have gone back to work
and
had a pretty good existence but like now
i'm financially independent just having
um without having to work full-time
or do anything that i don't want to do
what are the um what are the roots of
leverage
that you you have favorited over the
last few years
so investing is my main thing and that
is how i've also
sort of generated most of my wealth
um so what i'm looking for is
again asymmetries i don't know if you
want to get into investing at all
um but um yeah like
looking for neglected opportunities and
things that kind of intersect with my
own
skill set or experience or
um like things that are available to me
that aren't necessarily
available to everyone else so i'm not
talking about
s p 500 which every man and his dog can
go on and trade
things where you have some insider
knowledge or you have a personal
connection
um and therefore there's an opportunity
there might be an asymmetry to exploit
um and then the other things would
include
somewhat entrepreneurial ventures like
uh
yeah i don't know if i'd call them
entrepreneurial but uh
writing a blog uh writing this book i've
just finished where
you are having a punt your uh you know
you
you the downside cost is the time it
takes you to write the thing and
you know sort of pay for various
expenses and then you give yourself a
shot
at again collecting quite a large upside
whether that comes
financially um it's infamously difficult
to make money
through books but you're it's always
possible that you get the
the sleeper hit or the runaway hat and
then also in terms of um
creating other opportunities so
broadening your
reach and your audience and um you never
know who's gonna
read it and who's gonna get in touch so
uh yeah i've been
yeah i suppose i spent my sabbatical
collecting those kind of options like
meeting new people and trying some
uncertain ventures
that don't have a city paycheck
associated with them and then
yeah i've just been lucky that some my
stable of options have started paying
off
um interestingly after i'd written
almost all of the book so
this is not a sort of one of those
things where you create a cute story
after the fact to
explain uh your success like i didn't
know that this would happen but i was
putting myself in the
best position possible for it to happen
i love it man it's speaking in naval
language
you're leveraging on media
and capital and
the one that i feel like naval actually
misses off
which is kind of that the social slash
network slash renown
effect um and it's a kind of a
combination of all of those
is there an elephant in the room talking
about what you've just brought up there
and then the point i made before about
front loading your wealth
is there a bit of an uncomfortable
elephant in the room that there is
if you want to have a family there is a
little bit of a time bracket on this
that we need to spend a little bit of
time avoiding debt and accruing
fat stacks of cash we also know
for most of us we don't want to be a
parent to a newborn child at 50
so there is a kind of a window in terms
of
long-term lifestyle design that we need
to
slot ourselves into and for women the
window perhaps is made even smaller
although uh statistic from 2019 in the
uk
more women had children over the age of
40 than under the age of 20.
that yeah wow your cool start but you
you understand the
paradigm i'm talking about i do yeah
you're absolutely right but i think the
the
the good news is that it's not
necessarily
a biphasic thing where you're in this
mode now and then you switch to this
mode
after a certain point or because you're
having a family or whatever it might be
you can sort of move in and out of
different modes i'd probably
again go back to the exploring and
exploiting thing
um or you know risk on or risk off modes
and you can you can do that like
multiple times throughout a lifetime
so um my preferred model
is for a young a young person
first spend some time actually building
some career capital i reckon that's
always the way to go
and what i mean by that is accumulate
some skills
get paid to be less dumb basically get a
get a regular job um you know
like you you'll also meet people through
the job hopefully
um and make sure you repay your student
debt if you have
if you have one or at least have it have
a crack at it and also learn
how the workplace works as well learn
how to have a disagreement with your
boss learn what it is to get up at 7am
every day
etc etc yeah
yeah and maybe get a taste for what you
don't want in life too i suppose
um yeah like it's that thing i don't
know if yeah if anyone who's ever done
like manual labor
or maybe worked in a hospitality or a
restaurant
i think um if you're in a [ __ ] job
um not that i'm saying all those jobs
are [ __ ] i just mean if it happens to be
a shitty version of that job
that's pretty good motivation right like
um
you don't want to you don't want to uh
you don't want to think of yourself like
40 years from now doing the same thing
so i think there's sort of a character
building element to it as well
um where everyone should really have to
do have to do that but anyway you so you
go through a phase where you're trying
to be
useful when you know you're young and
dumb you don't know anything like
just pick up pick up skills become
useful
then maybe you do your exploration where
you start
maybe you go out into the world and you
take risks because you don't have a
mortgage
necessarily you don't have kids at that
point
this is it's not a surprise that so many
entrepreneurs are
in there even in their late teens or
early 20s like it makes perfect sense
then if your ambitions don't work out
and
you want to have a family or whatever
you can take risk off you can um
you know sell your business if you got
it started or just sort of sort of work
a regular
salary job and uh and and step things
back
but that's not the end of the road so
interesting
uh statistics i think the most
successful entrepreneurs
tend to be in their 50s or certainly
older
like the zuckerbergs of the world are
actually
um there's a lot of them but that
doesn't actually necessarily
uh relate to their success and it might
even be the opposite
they're incredibly rare there's a really
famous
diagram floating around a couple of
years ago where it was talking about the
founders of some of the biggest
companies in the world and when they
founded the companies and he's like bill
gates in his 50s and
steve jobs and blah blah blah blah blah
blah the only reason i can see
that we have adolescents worth billions
and billions of dollars is a function of
the fact that silicon valley's
valuations of companies has become
completely detached from their actual
worth
and it's more a quirk of the particular
way that our economy's set up at the
moment
i.e silicon valley doesn't know what the
[ __ ] it's doing
and is just chucking chucking money
at anything that moves in a desperate
attempt that it's going to go to the
moon
so yeah i i i i totally agree man you
can win at
almost every stage of life now there's
these kids these like seven i remember
this seven or eight year old who had a
youtube channel reviewing toys and he's
like one of the biggest youtubers
in the world a couple of years ago and
you can flip that round to the
the warren buffett story where you make
65 oh you make 90
of your net worth after your 65th
birthday you know like there is a full
lifetime of success opportunities and
you really
as long as you're never out of the game
you only need to hit that moonshot once
ideally earlier on because then you get
more time to enjoy it
but you only need to get it right once
yeah
yeah no you're absolutely right um i
mean my
own personal plan was if my little
ventures didn't pay off
um i was because i do quite want to have
a family at some point
i thought that i would return to the
workforce
and you know have a reasonable job and a
good career
and maybe do the kids and house and
family thing
and then yeah at some distant point down
the track uh
save up uh another stack of cash or get
in a
get in a good financial position and
then go do something wild again
you know like go uh try and start a
company or uh
you know sell everything and go
traveling or whatever it might be i
think dude
i think that kind of whatever you'd call
it that second
second youth when the kids leave home
i think we're going to see that more as
we've got more frictionless travel
people who've grown up with a traveling
mindset
and an entrepreneurial mindset rather
than the kids leaving home and your
parents retiring to the country
it's like the kids leave home and your
parents retire to
five different countries a year being
their plate their way
their way around the world doing all of
the stuff they just didn't quite have
time to complete when they were 25.
um and i think that's going to be super
cool i certainly know
given my wanderlust and it sounds like
you've got the same
that would absolutely be something that
i would be looking to do like not just
going away on
wanky dfds seaways tours and cruises
which like everyone's mum and dad seem
to be obsessed with at the moment
like you know going and heading off to
all the countries that you didn't get
chance or going on an expedition or
going dog sledding you know all that
sort of stuff
i think that yeah hopefully we'll we'll
see that and it'll be really
it'd be a really [ __ ] cool world if
that was the case and it's also going to
plug a
ton of wealth and income into
more varied countries you're going to
take wealth that's being created in the
developed world and plug it into the
developing world in a really nice way
yeah that's right it's even doable with
kids in tow i mean i don't know
how much of a sort of logistical mission
that is but
when i've been wandering around i've met
a bunch of families who are actually
doing the
nomadic digital nomad lifestyle
with their kids and it's it's pretty
cool for the kids because they get to
you know i'm thinking of this family who
they've got two young boys and the boys
are an entire school
learning thai at this formative age and
that's normal for them that's their life
um so yeah i think that can be that's
even a possibility as well as to make it
so that
so many options so many options richard
right so you've got um you've got these
10
principles for optionality and we've
kind of gone through
a few of them but there's some in here
that i think are really cool so can we
do a sort of a quick fire and have you
just explained some of these to us
yeah of course perfect so number two
sorry number three beware of geeks
bearing formulas
yeah so um
there's a okay so in the world of
finance
uh people love to come up with very
fancy models that they think have some
predictive power about what's going to
happen to
the stock market or oil or bitcoin or
whatever it might be
um and they use these models
to decide how much risk they're willing
to take in terms of asset allocation and
timing and
all these kind of decisions that they
have to make now when people do that on
their own behalf
that's okay you know you can be a trader
you can you can go on
wall street bets you can you can have a
play and
if you screw up then because you know
because your
fibonacci retracements uh were wrong or
whatever um
like that's on you and and um
and you know maybe it's a learning
experience or something right
but the the danger is that everyone has
exposure to the financial system as a
whole
and people who are making these kind of
decisions on your behalf because
you know they're investing your
retirement fund for you or
a pension fund or whatever it might be
so
um there's this tendency throughout
human history but especially in the
financial realm to
sort of put have too much confidence in
these
uh and these predictive models which
only ever offer a very
simplified version of of like a complex
chaotic system and then when the models
are wrong
things work out very very badly so
during the the gfc for example actually
during the credit crunch
um yeah that uh this is the story our
account in the book where
the goldman sachs guy whose fund has
just lost 30 or something
is saying like oh this was a 20 was a 25
standard deviation move
um outside of our models and it happened
multiple days in a row like
um it's a it's a total freak accident um
and the funny thing is that like these
freak accidents happen all the time
and it's not that it's not that the
universe is just um sort of taking the
piss
it's that the models are broken the
models are wrong
um so the the more general uh lesson to
sort of
extrapolate out from that is just um
if you're making any kind of decision
that's based on
an equation or a model also very popular
in the
financial independence retire early
movement
just don't put all your don't put all
your faith in it just
uh remain open to the possibility that
you might be wrong or that your model
might be wrong and sort of plan
accordingly um because historically
if you sort of trust in the numbers too
much like you know so-and-so is a sure
thing
uh you will be uh you will be proven
wrong
uh in a in a sort of a devastating
faction
around about once every decade as well
yeah yeah yeah i mean it will happen in
your lifetime yeah
for sure number five generating better
options
is much more important than trying to
make perfect decisions
if you think about when you
go you're going through daily life and
you're just presented with this
massively expensive array of options and
i mean expensive in terms of
attention and and mental bandwidth
and the vast majority of them just don't
matter so we're sort of blind to them
because we are so used to it but like
what clothes you wear what exactly what
brand
of cereal you're eating and all the
product selections that you make
the route that you drive the people you
associate with the emails you check
the websites you look at blah blah blah
blah like
if you add all of that up um we're
talking about like
millions of branching paths in front of
you at any given point in time
you could order anything you want um you
could look at any website on the entire
internet
or watch any tv show or film so
a lot of people try to optimize
those branching trees of possibility
so sort through the umpteen different
brands of detergent and figure out the
exact best one for me
or um you know like find out the exact
tv show that i should watch or uh you
know like
basically putting a ton of thought into
these decisions that don't have
any sort of asymmetric payoff because
you know you you choose the uh
you choose this brand of laundry
detergent over that one like it's not
going to be sort of wildly exciting
either way
your whites are lighter or whatever um
so the point that i'm making there is
that
you don't need to worry about the vast
majority of
those of choices that are presented to
you in daily life
you're much better off sort of pruning
quite a lot of those pathways
and trying to put your channel your
efforts into
looking for the actual asymmetric
opportunities that are going to be
powerful to you
so instead of
so instead of walking down the breakfast
cereal aisle
and trying to decide which type of
cereal you should eat
the higher a higher leverage option to
be thinking about is like
um do i want to be eating
cereal or you know like do i want to
have breakfast at all what is the
concept of breakfast like is this just a
myth sold to us by
mr kellogg or whatever right so like i'm
um the point being not that you should
skip breakfast but just that like
uh maybe that's a maybe that's a more um
interesting uh potentially rewarding
option to think about than like the very
specific
uh difference between one brand and the
other instead of scrutinizing ingredient
panels and that sort of thing
so that's my sort of go ahead sorry
don't go on
going one level of abstraction um with
my
with my tinfoil hat on um
my conspiracy theory is that like i
don't know if this is an
an exact deliberate ploy or not but um
when you have all these options sort of
dazzling you
you're essentially trapped and this is
the this is what the
this is what the consumer capitalist
system wants from you is to
keep you obsessing over this narrow
range of standardized options so that
you don't make the big
uh high leverage decisions to you know
stop
consuming in certain ways or change up
your
your life in a more meaningful way
because you're just constantly
trying to make these low level boring um
low payoff decisions
sorry go on you're going to say
something yeah so
the illusion of choice that we're given
as a consumer still traps us in the
matrix of making decisions as a consumer
it doesn't actually allow us out of the
maze it just gives us different flavors
of cheese within it
yeah i love it that's a great way of
putting it um one of the things i
thought first off
a good heuristic i suppose would be to
take one step of abstraction back
from the question that you're asking and
just think about it from first
principles about like do i need to do
this
do i need to do x uh well i get my car
cleaned every saturday okay
well like could could you get away with
getting it cleaned every other saturday
do you actually need to get it cleaned
at all like what's gonna happen could
you get it cleaned every six months
is there a different way that you can
get it cleaned can you go for a machine
as a hand washer this that and the other
another thing that it made me think
about is a naval quote
play stupid games win stupid prizes
and that very much i think talks about
the it speaks for a number of different
things but one of them
is the obsessing that we happen to have
over easy decisions because it allows us
to push away the difficult ones
so i'll never forget uh this is when i
was like maybe 23
24 said you know i was on my way to
buying my first house and i was
the director of a pretty successful
events company and i had
a fair bit of money behind me and i
remember i was i must have spent
five minutes debating between two
different types of yogurt based on the
deal that was on it was like
four for three pounds or like
like seven for eight pounds but there
were different yogurts and there was
some different flavors and
this one's this one's got a little bit
more protein but there's a little bit
more trans fats in the other one
and i remember i had to take that step
back go one level of abstraction away
and go
chris what what on earth are you doing
like this is this is
absolutely insane in the time you were
here you could have gone home and done
something
with far more leverage that would have
genuinely added value to your life
but it's because i hadn't made the
decision around which mortgage broker i
wanted to use or because i hadn't
you know the hard the hard thing i
hadn't sent the application off to
whatever
lawyer company that's what i was hiding
from
and yeah i really that play stupid games
win stupid prizes
also ties into it's a really easy way to
identify the negatively asymmetric games
that we're talking about so stupid games
is unprotected sex a stupid game is
texting whilst driving
a stupid game is putting your entire net
worth into
some expert algorithm trading advisor
that
some kid on instagram's decided to tell
you that you should use
and another one of those the most the
most obvious one which really struck
home at me that when i realized it
was what is the prize you win
for always responding to messages within
24 hours
because we all do that we all check our
inboxes of social media
instagram twitter facebook whatever it
might be tick tock
we all i don't even i don't know if tic
toc has an inbox
we all check those but what's the prize
that you get for being the fastest
replier in the land
like genuinely these people especially
as you start to accrue a little bit of
social capital and you get
more incoming than you have outgoing and
most of the incoming is
people wanting something from you
whether it be
an answer to a question or just the
sense of belonging to
do whatever like that's cool and
satiating that desire is is
is fine and it's a nice way to connect
but what's the prize that you win for
being the fastest person on the trigger
for that
it's absolutely nothing it's noise not
signal
and that the prize that you win is that
people expect that from you as well
in the future and then it sort of
becomes a trap of your own making it's
occurring so
yeah yeah yeah i mean this is that's my
that's my excuse for why i only
reply to emails once a week or something
thanks thanks for giving me that excuse
that's fine um spectacular success is a
matter of putting irons in the fire
yeah so this comes back to the idea of
looking for these asymmetric
opportunities and following your systems
day in day out
um basically my frame on luck
is that quite a lot of
success in life does boil down to luck
of one
variety or another you know perhaps the
sort of
the genetic blessings that you've been
bestowed with or not been bestowed with
or your parents of
childhood traumas or whatever it might
be um but
you can't be fatalistic about it and
sort of blame your entire
station in life on uh you know
deterministic events
you you actually do have to take
responsibility so how do you balance
that
um it's not it's it's it's clearly not a
matter of just
uh you know vibing with the universe and
putting out
your intentions the secret style but
it's also
um uh yeah it's also not to say that
there's nothing you can do
so my frame for optionality is well you
can make your own luck
so look for those asymmetric
opportunities
and just snap them up just build a
portfolio
over years and you don't
know you can never be sure if
they will pay off if you take one of
these speculative plays
and and probably they won't uh you know
the the
chances are against you in any given one
of them but the idea is you're building
a portfolio
one of them is going to pay off at some
point in time um
at which point uh you're going gonna be
okay so
you just keep stacking up opportunities
wherever you see them
and maximizing your chances of getting
lucky so you can't there's no guarantees
i can never say
you're definitely gonna um you know all
your dreams are gonna come
gonna come true and you know life's
going to be sunshine and lollipops but
like
you can definitely put yourself in the
position
of uh of getting a transformative upside
and it's that it's that stoic principle
again of
focus on the things that are within your
control the universe could
could either make you or break you at
any point along the way
but you can you can give yourself the
best possible chances of actually
getting a good outcome
hoarding options indefinitely is for
cowards
right so
if you are on your desk bed
and you're very wealthy then then um
one view of the world is that you've
done very well for yourself and are
admirable
and another view of the world is that
you're [ __ ] up because you know it's
that
that jesus thing that uh you know
a camel will pass through the eye of a
needle more easily than a rich man will
make it into the
into the kingdom of god so um i entered
into heaven sorry so
uh optionality has diminishing returns
because it's sort of raw potential and
you don't want to just be sitting on raw
potential indefinitely
it's very useful to always maintain some
level of optionality but
the point is to take risks like the
point is to do something
and leave the world in a better place
and you found it so
looking at money for example uh if you
have a bunch of money and you don't
deploy it anywhere i you know you just
sort of have it
uh muldering away under your mattress or
whatever it might be
you could have invested that money you
could have you have deployed the capital
to the place where it can actually
be do the most good or
you could have spent and put it back
into the economy or you could have given
it to someone who
will get a much higher return on
investment from that money so
if you're just hoarding options until
the end of time
my argument is that once you have made
good
once you've got yourself in a
comfortable position you're taking care
of you and yours
um i think it is sort of a not a
i don't i don't necessarily want to
frame it as a requirement but like it's
a very
attractive opportunity to use your
expanded range of choices
to help open up other people's uh
options and
capabilities just because you've already
tapped out you've hit the point of
diminishing returns you don't need more
opportunities you don't need more money
you don't need more friends right these
things uh
you can't have an infinite number um
it's not going to help you
but it'll be transformative to other
people so this is sort of my
my sort of preaching bit but like yeah i
would like to see people
um open up their options uh
yeah in a selfish way because why not
but also then use their position to
uh to help out other people i suppose
this
isn't just limited to financial either
so you can imagine someone perhaps
in a relatively okay middle class
position
who's maybe had a ton of different ideas
you know for invention maybe they're
maybe they're a low-level engineer or a
coder or something like that
but it was safe for them to stay within
the particular firm that they were at
and they made it to
55 and got a big fat pension because
they've been with them for 30 years
but had they decided to deploy on some
of those options
they could have had so much more
flourishing they would have felt better
the world would have actually been
raised up the whole consciousness of the
world would have been improved because
of whatever the cool thing is that
they're going to do
so that would be hoarding options in one
way and then i suppose as well
people can hoard their networks it's
built into my blood because
my business is that of a club promoter
that i
adore linking people in uh this guy this
guy you need to get him on your podcast
and
this author need you should speak to
this person and they're probably sick of
it
i promise they're giving me constantly
sending emails like
poor greg mcewan that wrote essentialism
like i've become his booking agent like
constantly
mate you need to go on ben bergeron's
podcast and this guy loves you and this
guy loves you
it's just as well he's got an assistant
so he's not being hassled with it but my
point is that a lot of the time you can
imagine someone would not only hoard
perhaps money they would hoard
intellectual wealth
and some of that would be conscious i.e
um
a fear of uh committing to it because as
soon as you
put a target or a goal out into the
world you give yourself the chance of
not achieving
it which is failure which is scary but
another side of it would be someone
consciously doing it
i don't want to share my insights about
the financial market
my networks about this my spare room in
the house which is currently
unoccupied a lower rental rate that
allows a
family to move in or all of these
different things there's a ton of
different ways that people can be
cowardly by not
acting on options and
certainly this year for me i've thought
that
trying to uh on the side of action
first in my experience we
all are quite hesitant creatures and
that makes sense because we're both
predator and prey evolutionarily which
is an odd situation to be in
we can be eaten by stuff but we also eat
stuff so
we're tentative by nature but
erring on the side of action david
allen's two-minute rule was like a
really good one for just day-to-day
stuff
but even bigger than that okay what
would it take for me to get this
the minimum viable product of me
starting this thing going
or me beginning that friendship with
that person or me
saying something to that girl over the
far side of the room or
pick whatever it is that you want having
that conversation with my boss that i
think treats me a little bit badly
all of these different things until you
put them out into the world until you
actually decide to commit
they're just notions they're just
[ __ ] ephemeral clouds these
weird thoughts that no other human
except for you
are going to be aware of and erring on
that
action first mindset is something that i
definitely want to cultivate more in
myself
and i think a lot of the people would
benefit from too
yeah i agree i think especially if uh if
the costs of doing so are minimal and
it's basically like a
motivational issue or um yeah just
pulling finger
like just make a little experiment make
a small bit and then iterate right like
if it you know
you'll learn something from it but yeah
i like that framing i think you should
definitely be
trying to get more data about the world
as quickly as you can
which will usually look like doing
something just make sure it's a
reversible
thing or that it doesn't um expose you
to
any kind of large obligation yes um
and then take that and then take the
action yeah uh
what is a concept from talib that more
people need to know about
one that perhaps isn't as common as the
black swans and anti-fragility and stuff
like that
yeah um i love his uh his idea of a
barbell strategy well it's not actually
talib's idea but he does write about it
which is basically uh
taking a sort of uh bimodal approach to
life where you're
extremely extreme and aggressive in one
particular
domain and then you're very conservative
like hyper conservative
uh at the same time so you think about
like a yeah like a barbell there's one
big lump
and then there's another big lump and
then there's nothing and you know
there's just a thin line in the middle
so i've i've found that really useful um
in all sorts of areas actually so uh
just to give you
an example um i have this like barbell
strategy for buying stuff
so what that means is i want to have the
best in class
stuff uh things that really bring me joy
and that i love and that
might be quite expensive um and that are
you know very good quality
or i want to have like whatever the
cheapest version of that is like the
very
the thing that i pick up at the thrift
shop without giving any particular
thought to
or the thing maybe i buy some fast
fashion item or something because i
don't particularly care about it
and then i want to have nothing in the
middle i don't want to have like middle
of the road
stuff where i have to think about it and
it's not that great
or i pay quite a lot of coin for it and
um it's not going to last me very long
so yeah i kind of i found that quite
quite liberating
thinking about also forces you to think
about like
what again what is what is worth having
what is worth
concentrating on what are some of the
examples of products that you've applied
that thought process to
yes so i have um uh
there's a there's a community called buy
it for life on reddit which i think is
pretty cool
and well maybe i'll give you some
context i've been traveling for
about uh four years since i quit my job
and i've been living
out of a suitcase so i haven't owned
anything and i got rid of i got rid of
everything before i left
so i had my sort of core kit of
clothing that i could wear over and over
again it's made out of merino wool
um and that's expensive and then i put
some thought into acquiring
and then i'd also just pick up sort of
bits and pieces as i was traveling
um with basically no thought put into
them like you know a t-shirt for working
out or whatever
and then if if it gets dirty or stolen
or something i don't care
it's just you know it cost me two
dollars or whatever it might be um
and then since coming back to new
zealand i'm sort of thinking of moving
into getting settled down a little bit
and
actually wanting to acquire positions so
i'm using the principles of this bite
for life community
to think about what are the things that
uh i will have
that i could potentially buy forever so
i'm right now right now i'm
researching uh chef's knives and pots
and pans
yeah i want to get it once and i want to
look after it and be intentional about
it
and care for it forever so this is on my
um
hyper sort of aggressive expensive end
of the barbell
um something that i will that will i
will use every day i'll get a lot of
utility
out of and pleasure out of um and that's
worth actually diving through that
annoying consumer capitalism uh
labyrinth war
but i don't want to do that like with
the middle of the middle of the road
stuff
and do it five years later when this one
crepts out on me you know
um yeah that is cool i had a rory
sutherland
on the show recently uh behavioral
economist from ogilvy advertising one of
the
most unique force of nature humans on
the planet
and he was talking about exactly the
same thing
and he spoke about how he thinks middle
of the road fashion is dead
so the marks and spencers are the
debenhams of the world which is
sort of 50 quid for a pair of jeans or
you know
35 quid for a t-shirt is
just from a psychological perspective
totally mute because you get a
particular
rush when you get a bargain when you get
a
wear it once for a fiver piece of
clothing and you also get
a nice rush and a sense of satisfaction
when you buy a 130 quid pair of replay
jeans that you know are going to be
around for a decade
but you don't really actually get any
sense it's just how i've
i've paid a fair price for a fair item
like this isn't exciting
like it's it's okayly made i'm not i'm
not really that excited about it i'm
gonna have to care about it but i didn't
really pay that much to care about it
that much
it's just so vanilla and yeah man the
the barbell strategy is one
also that i'm a huge fan of from talib
richard mann
i really really have enjoyed today it
feels like we could have
done many more of these and perhaps we
will do in the future optionality how to
survive and thrive in a volatile world
will be linked in the show notes below
on amazon
if this has been the sort of thing that
you've enjoyed today then i highly
recommend that you go and pick it up
any other things that you want to plug
where else should people check you out
online
um yeah i think come and say hello at my
blog which is
thedeepdish.org i encourage people to
reach out and say hello because you know
i want to
build it about my network and it's one
of those cheap options to take out
um and yeah if you want to know about
the book go to optionalitybook.com and
you can see a little preview and some
what people are saying and also get
links to the various retailers
awesome man thank you so much for today
oh thanks for having me chris um
you